heureusement tous les
situations humaines sont heureusement
paradoxes c'est toujours le paradoxe qui
nous sauve c'est l'un des monstres
sacrés de la littérature contemporaine
qui nous a quittés ce mardi 11 juillet à
l'âge de 94 ans Milan Kundera l'auteur
d'une des plus puissantes réflexion sur
la condition humaine vivait avec sa
femme verra dans le centre de Paris où
il menait inexistence discrète fuyant
les médias tour à tour idéaliste
communiste dissident is staliniens puis
contenteur de la modernité occidentale
Kundera reste à bien des égards un
écrivain mystérieux et inclassable qui
était ce génie peu locas et ennemi de la
société du spectacle Milan voit le jour
en 1929 a pour nous dans ce qui était
alors la Tchécoslovaquie à 18 ans il est
tout feu tout flamme il écrit ses
premiers poèmes et adhère au Parti
communiste mais très vite la vie du
jeune écrivain bascule Kundera se heurte
à l'imposture du socialisme d'État moi
aussi j'ai été dans la ronde c'était en
1948 les communistes venaient de
triompher puis un jour j'ai dit quelque
chose qu'il ne fallait pas j'ai été
exclu du parti et j'ai dû sortir de la
en 1950 il est exclu du parti ses idéaux
se brisent de cette déception née son
premier roman au titre éloquent la
plaisanterie ce livre que Louis Aragon
qualifié tout de suite d'oeuvre majeures
expose la confrontation tragique entre
la vie intime de l'individu et la
fiction d'une idéologie collective le
communisme stalinien l'optimisme et
l'opium du genre humain l'Esprit Saint
pue la connerie vive Trotski la
répression dans le sang du Printemps de
Prague en 68 marque un nouveau tournant
Kundera dit non à la soviétisation de
son pays et entre en dissidence déjà le
jeune écrivain défend ce qu'il défendra
toute sa vie la véritable culture
européenne et ses traditions alors
menacées de disparition par l'idéologie
communiste ces romans risibles amours la
vie est ailleurs sont de véritables
plaidoyer anti-totalité mais depuis 1967
Kundera est interdit de publication dans
son pays bientôt étouffé par une
atmosphère pesante il affirme ne plus
vouloir écrire c'est alors que ces
admirateurs et amis lui proposent l'exil
en 1975 Milan Kundera fait le pas il
rejoigne la France avec sa une nouvelle
page s'ouvre alors pour le grand
écrivain en 1981 il se fait octroyer la
nationalité française par François
Mitterrand et Élie Paris comme sa
deuxième ville natale trois ans plus
tard paraît son œuvre phare
L'insoutenable légèreté de l'être qui
lui apporte une réputation planétaire
notamment grâce à son adaptation au
cinéma par Philippe Kaufman et
Jean-Claude Carrière en 1988 il y pose
une question centrale face à l'absurdité
de la vie l'homme doit-il trancher entre
insouciance et lourdeur d'âme sa période
française n'est pas faite de joie
uniquement en 1979 Kundera et déchu de
sa nationalité tchèque rompant avec son
passé douloureux il n'écrit plus qu'en
français et va jusqu'à interdire la
traduction de ses livres dans son pays
natal c'est détracteurs affirment que
depuis son exil en France il a tourné le
dos à ses compatriotes et aux dissidents
restés au pays mais surtout comme le
célèbre dissident russe Alexandre
solgenitsi Kundera a trop souffert du
mensonge chez lui pour supporter de le
voir en Occident plus que critique
envers le pseudo progressisme de la
modernité ils fonde avec Alain fil que
nous crotte la revue Le Messager
européen en 1981 il t'inquiet pour
l'avenir de la culture qu'ils sont
menacé un jour toute la culture passée
sera complètement réécrite et
complètement oubliée derrière son rôle
righting si la société soviétique
cultivait la négation du passé
traditionnel celle de la modernité
occidentale souffre d'un autre fléau le
bavardage médiatique qui tue l'intimité
dans la fête de l'insignifiance l'un de
ses derniers romans il décrit notre
époque comme d'autant plus drôle qu'elle
a perdu tous sens de l'humour comment en
effet vivre dans un monde sans mémoire
devenu la proie du spectacle et de la
vulgarité marchande génie inclassable
Kundera était l'un des rares auteurs à
être édité de son vivant dans la
collection de la Pléiade Milan kundeira
nous a quitté esprit libre il trouve un
refuge en France et embrassa dans ses
écrits des horizons universels son
ironie et son génie on fait de ses
œuvres des classiques de notre temps
[Musique]